hugot clément voilà il ya une rumeur sur
i go clé bon je vous dirai tout derrière
puisque c'est dans le groupe canal c'est
parti en train de tourner un reportage
sur la situation précéda verte et sur ce
qui se passe ici lors du mercato a sonné
c'est la grosse info média du jour hugot
clément de retour sur canal + à la
rentrée deux ans après avoir quitté la
chaîne avec cannes barthez et toute la
vendée petit journal il devrait prendre
les commandes d'une nouvelle émission à
20h30
pile poil donc face à papa coup dur pour
quotidien à 28 ans le petit hugo est
devenu grand il ya quelques mois il
s'était envolé du giron barthez pour
voler de ses propres ailes sur combien
[Musique]
une véritable conte clément sur canal
bonne ou mauvaise idée
alors est-ce que j'ai des enfants je
vous le dis plus beaux clément et
combine hiver puisqu'il est chez combiné
l'excellent site un combi ni jo ni pour
l'instant il n'y a rien fait du tout et
canal je sais que voilà ils ont vu plein
de chaînes parce que depuis que clément
a quitté quotidien c'est un énorme
talent hugot clément donc plein de gens
l'ont vu sachez le et toutes les chaînes
sont intéressés par hugo clément et par
combiné donc voilà c'est pas plus canal
qu'une autre chaîne
sachez le c'est vraiment l'info pour
l'instant et et et aironi voilà vous le
disons cependant très bonne idée et vous
et moi et moi et moi j'ai jamais caché
que je l'adoré que je trouve excellent
maintenant moi je suis pas patron de
canal donc voila mais il serait voilà
dans les jolies donc voila mais c'est
vrai que c'est un garçon qui a beaucoup
de talent mais toutes les chaînes nous
rappeler je vous lis toutes les chaînes
ont appelé et je pense c'est bien